[Musica]
[Applauso]
facciamo un gioco per alzata di mano tre
domande facili facili a chi di voi piace
correre
sportivissimi ok a chi di voi proprio
non piace farlo è molto di più bene ma
se voi foste in ritardo per un
appuntamento importante per una nostra
passione il nostro sogno vostra tesi di
ieri una cosa che non potete perdere
chi è disposto a farsi una corsa per
arrivare in tempo
ok imperfetto bene
abbiamo tutti inclinazioni diverse tutti
passioni diverse
che per una cosa che per un'altra e per
i nostri desideri siamo pronti a fare
uno sforzo andare oltre
userò la metafora della corsa per
raccontarvi parte della mia vita e come
ho imparato affrontare le sfide che mi
sono trovato hunting quando ero giovane
lavoravo per fiat auto
avevo un ruolo importante un posto a
tempo indeterminato
il sogno di tante persone
mi alzavo la mattina correvo tutto il
giorno correvo correvo tutti i giorni
certo punto ho cominciato a sentire la
fatica e quindi ho cominciato a pensare
ma c'è qualcosa che non sta funzionando
va tutto bene
guardavo i miei colleghi felici di
correre la loro staffetta e io perché io
non sto bene ma tutto bene cosa che mi
manca
è così
evidentemente ho cominciato a pensare
che stesse correndo la corsa di qualcun
altro non la mia
ingegnere cominciato a farle conti ha
detto ma quante ore del giorno una
persona passa a lavorare
tante quanti giorni di una vita una
persona possa lavorare tantissimi quindi
ha detto ma se uno fa una vita così non
sarà mai abbastanza soddisfatto non
troverà la soddisfazione non sarà
vacanza super rilassante weekend super
divertente obi super interessante che
possa colmare questo vuoto
e quindi mi sono detto sono in crisi
allora ho pensato forse è l'azienda che
non va bene prova a cambiare azienda ho
cambiato paio di aziende continuando a
fare una mia carriera ma questa voce
dentro di me continua a crescere
e quindi ho capito che evidentemente era
proprio il posto fisso che era una cosa
che mi stava scomoda che mi stava
stretta non volevo essere un dipendente
dovevo fare qualcosa di mio
quando 40 anni da pensare calma non è
che magari ti stai sbagliando perché poi
se sbaglio fallisco perdo il lavoro
bootle calcio da un calcio ad una
carriera che mi troverò poi a esser
considerato un fallito è un pazzo che ha
dato anche un calcio nadal opportunità
che stava crescendo però questa cosa
ha un'energia dentro che dicevo ma io
sarò in grado di affrontare qualsiasi
criticità qualsiasi sfida che mi si
troverà davanti lo faccio tutti i giorni
perché non lo posso fare per una mia
passione
in realtà piccola confidenza ne ho
dovute affrontare più di quelle che mi
aspettassi però
mi sono buttato a quell età di 40 anni
tra essere un po elettrizzato da una
parte un po terrorizzato dall altra con
sgomento da parte di tutti amici e
parenti che mi guardavano pensando che
fosse definitivamente impazzito
ho deciso di dare un calcio alla
carriera
mollare il posto fisso e fare qualcosa
di mio
l'ho fatto per fondare green chic green
chic nei dieci anni fa nasce green chic
si chiamava armadio verde è una
piattaforma di moda secondhand che
permette in modo semplice veloce ed
economico di rinnovare il proprio
guardaroba quindi ci si libera di quello
che albergano utilizzato nell'armadio e
abbiamo tutti per prender qualcos'altro
che albergava in qualche altro armadio
tutto con un centro logistico molto
efficiente
l'ho fatto perché questa è una mia
passione siamo oggi abbiamo messo in
circolazione un pò più di un milione di
articoli di abbigliamento che altrimenti
sarebbero stati destinati alla discarica
quindi un inquinante risparmio di
miliardi di litri d'acqua migliaia di
tonnellate di co2 mi fa stare bene come
dicono i miei figli dice papà la fai
qualcosa di bene per il pianeta nel mio
piccolo
quindi
gasato parto e ovviamente le cose come
possono andare malissimo quindi parto
malissimo quindi ero ero partito con
tutte le buone intenzioni non
minuziosamente pensando tutto e invece
le cose non vanno bene e lì ho
cominciato avere il terrore di
incontrare amici e parenti con le
classiche domande del tipo
ma con va al lavoro e tu all'inizio
siamo appena partiti frasi di
circostanza che un po reggono ma la
lunga scricchiolano altri che mi
chiedevano ma tu lavori sempre per
quella roba là dentro di te dici ma
quella roba da sarebbe innovazione un
sogno una passione un progetto
imprenditoriale
ma funziona ma una frittatina di cazzi
tuoi mai
quindi mi trovavo
in una situazione molto complicata
perché in realtà innovare è difficile
il novara è difficile perché gli
innovatori sono quelli che traguardano
van aprono gli orizzonti anche per
quelli che arriveranno dopo sono quelli
che vedono prima di altri qualcosa che
ancora non c'è
aprono nuove strade
quindi non c'è una ricetta
e quindi mi sono mi sono trovato
immaginate edison non vi voglio
paragonarmi vino in 3d ma
quanto sarà stato difficile inventare la
lampadina ci sono frasi celebri che
dicono non ho fallito duemila volte per
inventare lampadina allo scoperto 1999
modi di non farla
quindi mi approccio all'inizio potrai
andare dopo un parare per voi non
immaginate
quante notti
l'ansia mi abbia tenuto sveglio
e
pensando di aver fatto una grande
cazzata
in realtà c'è la magia della notte buio
più silenzio fanno una grande magia che
fanno sembrare una grande cazzata una
gigantesca cazzata
quindi mi alzavo un po in preda
all'ansia andava a bere un bicchier
d'acqua e poi passava dalla camera dei
bambini li guardavo vivo due bambini un
anno e tre anni guardavo di fatto un
pazzo guarda gli errori dormivano sereni
pacifici e la loro tranquillità
trasformava la mia ansia non avendo una
botta di energia che mi serviva per
correre trovare nuove strade su cui
corre per trovare per raggiungere i
risultati quindi questa è stata una
erano scariche di adrenalina che dire ci
sono state fino per questi passati dieci
anni della mia vita quindi sono volati
in che mi sono volati gli ultimi dieci
anni della mia vita
mi sono come si corre per la domanda che
mi sono fatto ma lo rifaresti oggi
questo salto questa prende riprende
resta la stessa decisione e mi sono
detto sì sì perché avrei il rimpianto di
non averci provato
e come si corre per una propria passione
si corre
la mattina ti alzi per una passione
questo permea tutta la tua vita non c'è
una divisione netta tra il lavoro e la
vita personale si trova volte a correre
una maratona altre volte è una corsa da
centometrista che improvvisamente
diventa una corsa a ostacoli
io sono sentito spesso impreparato a
fare tutto questo questa corsa ma una
cosa è certa che se non avesse avuto
tutta l'energia questa passione che
facendo mettevo nel mio lavoro
sicuramente non sarei riuscito a saltare
fossi schivare e ostacoli prendere pali
è arrivare tra velata i traguardi che mi
stavo dando
quindi non è stato per niente facile
e voi
voi state correndo anche per voi stessi
o state correndo solo la corsa di
qualcun altro perché se non ne siete
certi
forse del momento di chiederselo il
momento di chiedersi e cominciare a
scoprire quale alla propria passione
correre per questo perché quello che non
vi farò sentire la fatica di fare a
superare qualsiasi prova che che avrete
davanti
qual è la ricetta la mia ricetta
personale
coltivare le proprie passioni
avere coraggio
una buona dose di pazzia e tenacia come
se non ci fosse un domani non basta mai
e
perché l'alternativa qual è
l'alternativa l'alternativa è accorgersi
che un certo punto stai correndo come
l'avrebbe nel recento stai correndo la
corsa di qualcun altro
e quindi
come si fa
bisogna avere il coraggio di fare pazzie
[Applauso]